what's going on guys this is rob and we
are covering uh dark crisis infinite
frontier technically speaking infinite
frontier is not officially part of dark
crisis but think of this is like the
jonathan hickman avengers into avengers
run for secret wars right like
technically this is not part of dark
crisis but it is right it just it leads
up to it right so it all just tells one
cohesive story now here's the thing
right there's gonna be uh some
explanations and stuff going on in this
right you know it's been a little while
since we covered dc but uh the cool
thing about this is you don't really
have to have read anything between the
end or i guess the ending of the whole
perpetua you know dark multiverse all
that kind of stuff and this which is
really the benefit because i wasn't
going to go back and read all that stuff
if i didn't have to this basically opens
up with what is in effect batman and it
looks like flashpoint batman crash
landing somewhere right and of course we
end up finding out this is earth 23. now
for those of you guys who aren't
familiar with this earth 23 is cool and
a lot of this really goes back to grant
morrison's multiversity so if a lot of
you guys who aren't familiar with that
grant morrison's multiversity was at the
time kind of a wonky story in retrospect
and given the kind of things that dc's
done specifically with the multiverse
it's become one of the most important
stories that have been written in the
last i don't know what would you say
like 15 years of dc comics uh that that
predated the events of final crisis back
in 2009 so it's a pretty significant
event pretty significant story what
multiversity did is it was really told
in a weird way but it kind of
reintroduced the idea of the multiverse
which was heavily used by dc comics when
the multiverse was brought back during
the events of the new 52 or at least
kind of modified during the events of
new 52 and then going into like the post
you know dr manhattan landscape which dc
never did anything with um that it kind
of continues on so the the multiversity
model of the multiverse is still kind of
the definitive standard that's used by
dc comics but the thing about this is
that earth 23 is the home of calvin also
known as president superman and this
guy's cool now for those of you guys who
know about that you're probably hyped
because things are gonna you know like
right off the bat when we're dealing
with like basically the house of heroes
and the the multiversal justice league
things are gonna get kind of wild and
they do so here's the thing
here's the thing and and what this does
is it really just kind of picks up with
this idea of the justice league facing
off against some threat that's out there
and of course his threat's not
considered like a great big huge deal
things are kind of defeated the day
saved done and done but on this reality
earth 23 the justice league as we know
it has largely shifted it consists of
the same kind of core members insofar as
like their powers or the namesakes they
follow so like a green lantern a
superman that kind of a thing but what
it doesn't include are the characters
that we're the most familiar with as
being core members of the justice league
so of course you have a green lantern
but it's alan scott you've got mr
terrific you have hall girl which is
always cool to see uh you've got these
characters right vandal savage is part
of the justice league on this on this
alternate reality it's cool now
characters like alan scott most people
are familiar with and the funny thing
about this is alan scott basically ends
up bailing out and taking off saying he
has to go meet with his son of course
meeting with uh with obsidian and then
when he dies there's a few things that
are kind of left ambiguous here from dc
comics those guys who were not familiar
with alan scott he was the first green
lantern dc ever published in terms of
like comic book publication history he
was the og green lantern initially it
was just a mystical ring that he got his
powers from it's really all it was and
he had a weakness to the to like wood
like physical wood it was weird comics
back then were kind of strange as time
progressed especially following the
introduction of future green lanterns
beyond hal jordan like jon stewart and
guy gardner and kyle rainer eventually
alan scott was brought into the fold of
the other green lanterns and made an
official member of the of the green
lantern corps given like an official
green lantern ring and so as a result of
that of course him meeting with obsidian
there's a few things we don't know so
obsidian and jade for those of you guys
who don't know are the children of alan
scott they were really more members of
infinity inc than they were jsa and the
relationship between those two groups is
that the justice society of america if
we go with the more recent iterations so
we we move away from like the old stuff
from before crisis on infinite earth and
we get rid of like that multiversal
concept the idea of the jsa really from
the 1990s going forward specifically
during jeff john's run uh really in the
2000s is that what you had is the jsa
operating as what were basically heroes
during world war ii and then once world
war ii came to an end and a lot of those
heroes retired it left the landscape
open for the new heroes that we're used
to so bruce wayne wonder woman superman
cal those guys infinity inc was kind of
the missing link between the two in the
sense that infinity inc was really the
offspring or the younger proteges of the
justice society of america continuing
that legacy on and so that's why despite
the fact that obsidian doesn't really
have powers identical to alan scott
although jade really had powers more
similar to her father uh than obsidian
did that they continued on as kind of
the kind of carrying on the legacy of
alan scott in infinity inc so again it's
a kind of a cool concept but really it's
just one of these things where they're
just kind of having a conversation
talking about stuff when it comes to
obsidian one of the things that happened
later on is he actually ended up
retiring from superhero antics um that
doesn't look to have happened at this
point in time the other thing that goes
on here and this is really more just
kind of filling in the gaps for people
uh who hadn't really been reading
anything or people who were kind of new
to dc because infinite frontier was
billed as a pretty significant build-up
to the events of dark crisis it's really
just kind of running over what we
already know right in the sense that
what you had at least was the whole
perpetua versus the batman who laughs
who had taken the power of dr manhattan
and that gravy a huge battle that
happened between the two of them the
multiverse basically being eradicated
and then being recreated uh presumably
through wonder woman by means of those
individuals who have created all of
existence who are just kind of these
nebulous ambiguous beings that exist out
there uh but the thing about it is
there's a lot that we don't necessarily
know in terms of obsidian himself and
it's not the most important thing what
is important here is that there was an
old jsa headquarters that was based in
gotham city and that's kind of where
they're operating out of but when alan
scott and obsidian get here the whole
place explodes and the initial thought
is that basically jade is stuck inside
because obsidian can't sense her life
force anymore right he can't sense her
presence like she's just not there and
so that's when he starts to freak out
wondering like what in the world is
going on with his sister now that's an
important thing because what it does is
it starts hitting on this idea of
superheroes vanishing people basically
being taken but what we end up doing
here momentarily is we switch over to
kind of an interesting situation which i
was surprised to see this if i'm being
honest with you guys so what you do is
you pick up in paris where you basically
talk about how the jsa headquarters has
been blown to pieces right just kind of
a newspaper or really like a digital
newspaper right a new story that was
being written about of course that was
tweeted out how it kind of exploded in
like green flames which indicates that
like maybe jade or somebody is involved
but with the explosion being what it is
and the fact that the energy based on
that explosion seems to emanate
superhuman energy what this does is it
leads to this realization that this is
cameron chase and she's basically being
met by director bones now for those of
you guys who are unfamiliar with them
and i imagine there's a lot of people
who are a lot of folks who are just like
okay i have no idea who these people are
and i don't know why they matter make it
make sense rob okay so here's the thing
in in dc comics you guys know amanda
waller the head of the suicide squad all
that kind of stuff amanda waller was a
multifaceted person meaning that she had
multiple groups and organizations
operating under her because it's one
thing to just send people in on some
crazy suicide mission and hopefully it
succeeds it's another to have the
information she needs to pull it off and
that information didn't just come from
like government satellites or things
like that the deo the department of
extranormal operations pretty sure is
what it was called uh was basically the
intelligence arm of amanda waller that
it was led by director bones so think of
them as superheroes policing superheroes
or monitoring superheroes different
things like that and not just
superheroes anybody with superpowers
meta humans in general um and so that's
really what's going on here cameron
chase was one of the absolute best
detectives they had and of course
director bones was highly capable as
well one of the funny things about this
guy he has skin the difference here is
that it's translucent you can't see it
but if you touch it it were to kill you
so that's why you see director bones
wearing gloves and that's why you never
actually see cameron chase touch him and
you probably you'll never see anybody
touch them at least they shouldn't uh
over the course of us unless they want
to die so that'll be kind of a focal
point if someone's going to get killed
off but this is really more director
bones just bringing cameron chase back
in saying the deo has been reformed now
again something that i want to want to
reiterate here this is all taking place
on earth 23. so we don't know exactly
what direction or exactly how the deo
operates if it functions under amanda
waller if it's different things like
that we don't know exactly how this
works we're really just kind of
speculating here based on what little
information we're given because the
reality is we never really saw a deep
dive into the universe of calvin of
president uh president superman we never
really saw that instead what we do is we
transition to uh to batman to thomas
wayne waking up and we get one of the
greatest characters to ever grace
comics which we knew was coming as soon
as we got president superman we knew he
was on his way ladies and gentlemen we
knew he was on his way as this person
begins to awake this group is talking
amongst themselves that this this ship
that he crash-landed in does not match
the material of any known universe in
the entire multiverse so it's kind of
strange nobody knows where he came from
or how he got here well he was brought
to this to the house of heroes because
he crash landed on president superman's
front lawn but or at least his parents
experience farm but the thing is the guy
starts to wake up and he is met by
captain carrick
captain carrot i love captain carrot
captain carrot's a super bunny and i've
you know i've seen your comments but
i've seen your comments of people who
are saying things that rob has this
irrational love for captain carrot why
does rob love captain carrot what's
what's the deal with rob and captain
carrot people have been shipping us in
your weird ass fan fictions it's we it's
it's strange man not even gonna lie i
read a couple of them i was curious
don't judge me i've read a couple of
them y'all are weird you're some weird
people just throwing it out there but uh
nonetheless
i love cat i don't know what it is i
just love captain carrot it's awesome
you may not love captain carrot but hey
at least he's not black bolt black bolt
sucks but the thing about this is that
uh this is ultimately of course thomas
wayne waking up trying to figure out
what's going on and he's met by the
arrival of president superman along with
the justice incarnate now one thing that
i always also want to reiterate here and
which i hope is true is that whenever
you see like the words of a team written
that way i'm really hoping that's how he
says it right you're in the house of
heroes and we are justice incarnate i
really hope that's how he says it like
that's the way it's said because i feel
like it would be amazing
but of course those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with multiversity justice
incarnate the house of heroes things
like that it's basically a multi a
multiversal justice league that it is a
justice league team you know essentially
composed of different people from across
the multiverse these are the core
members but they're not the only members
there's all kinds of members there and a
lot of them are reserves in the sense
they operate in their own universes
doing their own thing but when there's
any kind of a massive calamity they call
everybody together right so not every
superhero across the multiverse is part
of justice incarnate but a good chunk of
them are of course the mainstays as you
would expect the core members of the
justice league from virtually every
reality are usually members of justice
incarnate but of course thomas wayne
really just kind of says okay and the
reality that i come from like it's a
huge upgrade compared to the superman
who's there so one of the things that i
want to iterate we want to reiterate
here and one of the things that i want
to throw out here is that what it looks
like is this is not just some random
version of thomas wayne who exists out
there this is flashpoint thomas wayne
because those guys who recall the
flashpoint storyline the superman in
that universe was captured as soon as he
landed on earth and was taken to an
underground bunker by the us government
where he was constantly exposed to red
sun radiation so his powers never
manifested and even when they did i mean
he had all his strength and speed and
all that kind of stuff but he was all
emaciated because those muscles never
grew but the thing about this is of
course you end up having thomas wayne
who's like you need to get me in contact
with barry allen and when the question
when when he says this like the question
of calvin is like which one now of
course we know he's referring to earth
zero barry allen and the reason why is
those guys who don't know earth zero
barry allen that's the one that worked
with thomas wayne during the events of
flashpoint to basically try to gain his
powers back and to try to fix things so
the two of them have a strong history
together they've got a really really
lengthy history together just from the
events of flashpoint and how far
reaching that story was and in fact at
the end of it because of the the kind of
escapades and what had gone on thomas
wayne had made a request of barry allen
to bring a letter to his son in barry
allen's own universe right to actually
kind of communicate across the
multiverse to his own son it was pretty
touching it was a very sentimental
moment in that story but the thing about
this is of course you basically pick up
presumably after this kind of
conversation has taken place and this
idea that barry allen has kind of gone
on this mission at the request of calvin
to find what is in effect this dark you
know universe that exists out there this
one that just cannot simply be accessed
through conventional means and the way
that the at least the conventional as
far as barry goes the way we know that
is because historically speaking ever
since the events of flash of two worlds
where barry allen first met jay garrick
the original flash from dc comics barry
has the ability to vibrate through
realities right to vibrate from one
universe to the next and that's how he
usually usually travels the multiversal
space the only alternative which usually
deals more with time than anything else
is the cosmic treadmill but the but that
can be used to traverse the multiverse
itself if you're talking about going
back to a point where you know before a
universe came into existence as a result
of some decision that was made and then
ride the waves of that new universe into
its existence and then show up in that
alternate reality it takes longer and
it's less effective than barry just kind
of doing his thing but uh it is it is
also more it allows me to be more
precise in terms of where he's going
based on that particular context but the
reality here is barry cannot vibrate
into this alternate universe he doesn't
quite know why he simply just knows that
he cannot do it the way he normally
would so what he ends up doing here is
he basically vibrates through the
multiverse and picks up all this
multiversal energy and is really just
kind of building up his power because
for whatever reason there's a kind of
barrier or it requires more energy than
he possesses but ultimately he ends up
vibrating into this alternate reality
where he arrives on what's called earth
omega right seemingly the final earth is
kind of what it what it seems to be
called here but when he arrives on the
scene like immediately he's like okay so
things are a little strange right he's
recording this and of course sending it
all off to the hall of heroes and so on
but he talks about how this world has no
vibration there's no frequency in this
universe and so because this universe
has no frequency this is the reason why
justice incarnate could not travel here
because remember they travel from one
universe to the next the same way barry
allen does that every universe has its
own vibrational frequency if you can
hone into that frequency you can
literally vibrate there right you can
just kind of disperse your your
molecular structure into that new
universe and then just be there right
but the hall of heroes or justice and
cardiac couldn't do it very couldn't do
it because this place has no vibrational
frequency it's an anomaly right it's
seemingly cut off from everything else
but once he gets here he also finds out
the quintessence has basically been
killed now the quintessence as it was
initially presented to us in dc comics
that was one of those things that had
kind of been hit on over the years but
we really saw them as a major player
once you got to the whole like ending of
the dark multiverse storyline right the
conclusion of all that work that had
been done with the batman who laughs and
everything but the quintessence was in
effect a representative from each of
some of the more powerful groups or some
of the most powerful members uh beings
who existed in dc comics so you had the
phantom stranger you had the spectre but
you also had uh you had one of the
guardians of the universe right just
different things like that each one of
these guys was ridiculously powerful and
somebody had seemingly murdered them now
one of the things that's kind of crazy
here is that barry says there's no sign
of a struggle but those energy
signatures are off the charts he doesn't
know what to make of it but he doesn't
know how could it be that some of these
ridiculously powerful beings right the
specter phantom stranger especially
these guys who are nearly god level in
terms of power would basically be killed
and there'd be no sign of a struggle
either they submitted themselves to
their own deaths which seems highly
unlikely or some force out there was
able to take them by surprise and
destroy them now how this happened or
how it is this is this can be done is
explained in dog crisis don't spoil it
for yourself the build-up is much better
than if you just go and read it but the
thing about this is barry's just kind of
caught caught unawares he's like okay
like something's going on but whatever
this is is huge right like it's a
massive thing the problem is before he
has a chance to really send everything
off the way that he's supposed to he
starts going through these crazy
emotional states where he's like
exceedingly happy and giddy and then
he's like really irritated that kind of
a thing but his emotions are running
nuts and he's like what in the world is
going on here and that's when this voice
comes out of nowhere and it says you
should have stayed further away but i am
happy you're our first visitor you and i
have been down this path before haven't
we witnesses to a great crisis but even
after you triumphantly came back from
the dead you never tried to find me and
i gotta be honest that really hurts my
feelings only for us to find out this is
psycho pirate right now for those of you
guys who don't recall who don't know
about psycho pirate him and barry allen
go back like back back like the original
crisis on infinite earth's back right
psycho pirate was one of the only people
who remembered how things were after the
events of christ on infinite ursa come
to an end but psycho pirate and medusa's
mask of course as we've talked about
before allows him to manipulate the
emotional state of people so it's one of
those things where he can be a very very
dangerous person and in fact him being
here is done seemingly on behalf of some
force out there that's disembodied and
that we don't see and it simply says you
can toy with the flash after you fulfill
your promise but remember your role in
this story and that's basically it right
like that's all we really get about this
voice there's really nothing more beyond
it than that and so ultimately psycho
power it's like yeah there's a new
crisis coming barry allen and you're
gonna help us find something or rather
someone and so what you end up doing is
you transition to this diner in this
really really cool moment right you
transition to this diner where you have
like this guy who's just sitting there
and drinking a cup of coffee while you
have all these people who are debating
what's going on with the multiverse
because one of the things to know the
average person was not supposed to know
the multiverse exists they were not
supposed to be aware of the fact that
it's out there now it's it's as far as
we're aware we're not necessarily told
that this is anything other than earth
23 so presumably we're still on earth
23. i don't know if that's definitively
the case that seems to be the case but
we're not really given a clear-cut
answer here instead as this
conversation's going on it's this idea
that like the justice league had
basically saved everybody that reality
was essentially fixed so this seems to
indicate it is earth zero it's the main
dc universe because it was the justice
league in the earthly euro universe who
did seemingly save everybody but it's
one of those things where people kind of
see it in two different ways some people
see it as mass hysteria that it's all
just made up and it's nonsense other
people see it as an absolutely true
thing and in fact this particular girl
actually recalls the world ending not
everybody does and so it's one of those
situations where people a lot of people
who don't really believe the multiverse
was destroyed and recreated look at all
these people who were talking about how
they recall the multiverse ending and
everything kind of blinking out and
coming back and how they all share the
same experience as something like a
mandela effect right like they all
remember it but it doesn't mean it
happened because i don't remember it if
something that big did happen i would
remember it right like that kind of a
thing but in the midst of all this you
kind of have this great big huge fight
that breaks out you know between like
this guy who's pissed off about some
things that have popped off and so on
and so forth and now he was impacted by
it and of course this dude with the red
hair basically steps up and says no no
you need to go sit back down everybody
needs to chill in the middle of all this
this great big huge explosion happens
and you end up having like these these
folks that come in out of nowhere and
address the guy with the red hair as
arsenal roy harper which is awesome
right because roy harper let me tell you
something man this dude has been through
it like this guy has been through it
it's crazy everything that goes on with
roy harper right arsenal is a really
fascinating character this guy's a big
deal but what they also say here and
it's really context that's important
it's let's catch us an arsenal not let's
catch arsenal it's a arsenal one of many
arsenals right like a varying version of
arsenal so literally they seem to be
traveling around the multiverse and just
capturing roy harper's we don't really
know why we simply just know that they
are and so where this great big huge
fight breaks out ray harper is you know
he really kind of tackles this guy to
save his life you know knock him down
out of the the direction or out of the
path of a energy blast and that kind of
a thing that what goes on is roy
harper's just kind of met with this okay
uh this is crazy this giant like black
fist just pounds everybody like
literally knocks the roof off of this
whole place this whole diner and then
white harper is out but when he wakes up
he ends up waking up in a place he's
unfamiliar with only for us to basically
find out that roy harper has essentially
become a black lantern i mean it's crazy
right like it's crazy right like
literally roy harper just like knocks
the knocks the doors off this place like
these shadow folks are making their way
towards like this these these you know
enemy guys like these bad guys and it's
like what in the world is going on but
when roy harper wakes up he's a black
lantern right and he has quite and he's
quite literally creating black lantern
constructs more so than that these
constructs he's creating are different
iterations of himself so that's the
bigger question to ask here like what is
going on with this how did roy harper
become a black lantern with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace